(playful orchestra)
- Who did this?
(phone ringing)
- The push pin?
Invented by Edwin Moore, 1900.
- No, not who. (sighs)
Who put their DJ flier
up next to my DJ flier?
- That's Ezra's, he's the new IT guy.
- Ezra?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, isn't that a great name?
- Amazing.
- Ezra,
- Ezra.
(laughing)
- Aww, yeah.
- Yeah, it's a really cool name.
- It's a great name.
- Ahh, come on.
- What is it?
- My computer keeps jamming up.
- Oh, I'll buzz Ezra.
- Oh, perfect.
- Yeah.
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I got this. It's cool.
You don't need your
precious Ezra, you just...
- You made it worse!
- No, it's just gonna take a second.
- Harper.
- It's ok, guys, guys, Ezra's coming.
- Well, good, I'm glad 'cause then
he gets to see me do this.
- You missed terribly.
(upbeat funk music)
- If you guys didn't want to
go, you could've just told me.
- Uh, no, man.
- Wait, no. (laughing)
- No, no, no, we're totally going.
- We're going, we're going together.
- We're stoked.
- Ezra.
- Oh, hey, you must be Harper?
It's nice to finally meet you.
I've heard a lot --
- May I speak with you privately, Ezra?
- Sure, let me just uh...
- What?
(upbeat funk music)
- I'm all yours.
- Look I don't know what
your playing at here,
but this, this is my turf,
okay, and those guys,
those are my idiots.
- Look I'm sorry, I didn't --
- So, if I see one more
flier for a cool thing
or hear a new song that
you played for them
from someone they've
never heard of before.
Things are gonna get
really painful here, Ezra.
- Look I just thought that
that's where people post fliers--
- Some people post fliers there.
- Well I'm really excited to see you play.
What's your first song gonna be?
- I usually start with
"Welcome to the Jungle".
- Oh, that's cute.
- It's ironic.
- Yeah, sure, in a way.
- No it works, it get the crowd--
- Hey, I'm really sorry.
I hope my enthusiasm
didn't get the best of me.
It's kinda like a time I
stole a parking spot from Lance Butte.
Oh, you know what, you probably
don't know who that is.
I can see everything you type.
(playful orchestra)
(phone ringing)
- Oh I get it,
"Welcome to the Jungle".
- [Voiceover] Okay, okay, cool.
(laughing)
(orchestra tuning)
(internet dial up)